if there's one symbol of the drought
affecting large parts of southern Europe
is the salaries of war in Catalunya it's
now at less than six percent of its
capacity the level so low that about 4
000 fish had to be culled here over
fears the water would become too muddy
for them to survive
it's a desolate scene the 11th century
Church of santro madasau was once
submerged is now standing well above the
water level
usually we only see the tip of the
church it's worrying I live at an
altitude of a thousand meters and we're
starting to see dry trees up there too
Springs that were always plentiful
before no longer have water and you're
asking what's happening it's not raining
that's the answer
it has rained a little only a
significant downpour can reverse the
situation but with average temperatures
Rising it's difficult to predict when or
if that could come the needle of the
rain gauge stands idle
temperatures the increase is around 2
degrees over the past decades compared
to the average temperature at the
beginning of the 20th century is
this drought is very singular our data
recorded over a century shows there's
never been two years as dry as 2021 and
to fill the Gap the Alfred desalination
plant the biggest in Europe has been
working at full capacity since last
summer 2 000 liters of sea water is
turned into drinking water every second
this is present or future for areas
and our area here in Spain or the
meritorian area we have several roads
that we need another sources similar
like this to to guarantee the water
supply for the population is not the
only solution but it's a very important
part of the solution yeah
the South reservoir's main role is to
supply water to the Barcelona area where
tourists can double the population
during the high season
when it was first built back in the
1960s villagers had to be uprooted
because the reservoir was essential to
supply the ever-growing urban areas now
life is again disappearing from the area
because of the lack of water
the reservoir had become a popular spot
for lovers of water sports now it's a
mosaic of parched soil as seen more
reminiscent of drought in the
sub-Saharan Africa than along the shores
of the Mediterranean leaving the
reservoir one can only wonder if it
could ever be reversed Abdul Hamid
al-jazeera at the South Reservoir in
Catalunya